herzlich willkommen ja die schweiz sieht
sich gerne als vorzeige nation wir sind
stolz auf unsere qualität die demokratie
die humanitäre tradition und die
neutralität
es gibt aber auch ein ganz anderes bild
das die schweiz als complete sind zeigt
als nation die immer wieder beihilfe zum
bösen leistet ende november stimmen wir
über zwei volksinitiativen abdi genau
diese rolle der schweiz kritisieren die
konzern verantwortungs initiative und
die initiative für ein finanzierungs
verbot von kriegsmaterial in der
folgenden stunde wollen wir über die
zwielichtigen verstrickung der schweiz
reden denn die haben eine lange
tradition
beispiel kolonialismus
zwar hat die schweiz keine fremden
länder erobert und selber auch keine
sklaven gehalten vom sklavenhandel
profitiert hat sie aber sehr wohl oder
im zweiten weltkrieg da war die
offizielle schweiz zwar neutral
das hat sie aber nicht davon abgehalten
jüdische flüchtlinge an der grenze
abzuweisen und mit nazi-deutschland
geschäfte zu machen
ähnliche geschäfte gab es wie wir wissen
auch mit dem apartheid regime in
südafrika
und nicht zu vergessen das bankgeheimnis
es hat die schweizer banken in der ruf
gebracht als heimliche profiteure von
krieg und ausbeutung und es erschwert er
jahrelang den internationalen kampf
gegen steuerhinterziehung
ja warum wurde und warum wird die
schweiz immer wieder zu komplizen und
wie gehen wir mit dieser historischen
schuld
darüber rede ich mit meinen heutigen
gästen lea hunger ist historikerin
leitet das magazin nz geschichte und hat
über die globalen handelsbeziehungen der
schweiz geforscht
michael szewczyk ist professor für
philosophie in karlsruhe arbeitete acht
jahre an schweizer universitäten und hat
sich intensiv mit historischem unrecht
und der frage der wiedergutmachung
beschäftigt und schließlich geht es bei
hungry sie ebenfalls historiker
migrationsexperte und geschäftsführer
des kompetenzzentrums geschichte des
wissens in zürich herzlich willkommen im
3 daher ist machen die sie heute wollen
wir über einige dunkle kapitel der
schweizer geschichte er reden warum ist
diese aufarbeitung überhaupt wichtig
wenn wir über aufarbeitung von
geschichte reden ist es zunächst einmal
wichtig auch im blick zu haben dass wir
nicht über die vergangenheit reden also
das ist ganz wichtig wir schauen ich
einfach nur zurück auf die vergangenheit
und wühlen in der vergangenheit sondern
wenn wir über geschichte reden und
auseinandersetzung mit geschichte geht
es darum einen lebendigen zusammenhang
herzustellen zwischen vergangenheit
gegenwart und zukunft
und das ist eigentlich der zentrale
punkt das heißt wenn wir haben uns mit
geschichte auseinandersetzen verhandeln
wir immer auch die frage wie wollen wir
eigentlich zusammenleben wer sind wir
was sind die werte auf die gesellschaft
aufbaut und was sind vielleicht auch die
ziele die wir uns setzen und was sind
die herausforderungen und genau der
punkt an dem stehen wie es gibt viele
herausforderungen
ja soziale bewegungen ob das jetzt
frauenbewegung ist ob das die frage von
migration rassismus von globalisierung
ist klimawandel
da kommen herausforderungen auf die
gegenwart zu und um die bewältigen zu
können gerade in demokratischen
gesellschaft ist es wichtig sich nochmal
darüber zu verständigen wo kommen wir
eigentlich hin und wo wollen wir hin und
in dem sinne sollte man keine angst
haben vor streits über geschichte ich
bin ein bisschen vorsichtig mit dem
begriff der aufarbeitung
weil das so das bild zeichnet wir hätten
dann damit was abgeschlossen eventuell
eher eine erinnern an das thema gerade
heute gehe es wichtig das heißt
lebendige demokratie heißt sich mit
geschichte auseinandersetzen er in
diesem dreiklang von vergangenheit
gegenwart und zu heftig für wen machen
wir das eigentlich diese aufarbeitung
oder diese auseinandersetzung
gerade was historisches unrecht angeht
für die opfer von damals für die
hinterbliebenen oder für uns selbst kann
man das so sagen ja also die frage ist
sehr sehr berechtigt warum tun wir uns
das eigentlich an weil wir
auseinandersetzung mit einer
schuldhaften geschichte oder
möglicherweise schuldhaften geschichte
zunächst einmal sehr schmerzlich ist
also das kann bedeuten dass
familienverhältnisse belastet werden
einfach weil angehörige fragen stellen
nach dem verhalten der großeltern
generation
das kann bedeuten dass museen ihre
sammlungen aufgeben müssen
in akten der wiedergutmachung
historischen unrechts und das bedeutet
natürlich auch dass bestimmte nationale
kränkungen erlitten werden müssen
vielleicht ist man doch nicht so
vorbildlich wie man immer dachte und
dann fragt sich warum machen wir das
eigentlich und warum machen wir und ich
denke der eine punkt ist das eine eine
politische gemeinschaft im vernünftiges
interesse daran hat ihn in kontakt mit
dem historischen realitäten zu leben
wir wollen doch unser unsere politischen
und nationalen identitäten nicht
aufbauen auf illusionen sondern auf den
realitäten
das ist der eine punkt und der andere
punkt ist wir reden ja hier über dinge
die konsequenzen haben
ist ja nicht einfach ein historisches
interesse dass wir gruseln roman über
die vergangenheit und seinen schauen
sondern aus historischem unrecht folgen
dinge wir wir werden konfrontiert mit
ansprüchen von opfern die vielleicht
opfern historischen unrechts die
vielleicht schon lange zurückliegen aber
ihre geltung noch nicht verloren haben
das heißt und das knüpft jetzt glaube
ich an auch an dem punkt von herrn s
bahn die sie in dem wir uns unseren
unserer vergangenheit aufrecht die
stellen ändert sich auch unser
selbstverständnis des politischen
überhaupt nationen sind nicht nur
instanzen der vertretung des eigenen
interesses sondern sie sollten sich
verstehen als als moralische akteure die
ihre möglichkeiten nutzen um die
weltpolitik in einem positiven sinne zu
gestalten
jetzt gilt und galt der die schweiz
immer als neutral
trotzdem haben wir gesehen sie wurde oft
zur komplizin hat mit allen seiten
geschäfte gemacht auf mit den bösen wie
passt das zusammen frau haben ich sehe
komplizenschaft und gleichzeitig diese
neutralität
ja man muss sich wahrscheinlich
verabschieden von der vorstellung dass
es auf der einen seite so die schöne
geschichte gibt die neutralität die so
ein etwas ganz tolles ist dass wir uns
in der welt bewegt haben so als nation
die das verkörpert oder ausdrücke und
dann geht so die kehrseite davon nicht
stört diese begriff kehrseite ein
bisschen es suggeriert dass es ebenso
eine schöne seite gibt eine gute und
dann wenn man dann historische forschung
macht und dann ein bisschen nach hakt
dann kommt dann dieser dreck auf den
dunklen ecken und den können wir dann
auch noch im nachhinein so an die
oberfläche heben seine geschichte ist
viel komplexer geschichte ist immer ist
ambivalent geschichte geschichte hat von
anfang an beide seiten aber genau das
oder es ist sozusagen ein
die zwei perspektiven einer auf eine
feine sache jahres kehrt eben nicht nur
auf eine bestimmte seite immer es gibt
vielleicht fünf seiten oder in der
zwischen krieg
zeit wurde die schweiz mitglied des
völkerbunds zum beispiel da erfand man
einfach den begriff differenzielle
neutralität das ist dann kein problem
dann kann man sich in dieses milieu sehr
schön einpassen und sagen okay wir
beteiligen uns an wirtschaftlichen
sanktionen aber nicht an militärischen
während des zweiten weltkriegs so die
situation dann wieder anders aus da hat
man das haar neutralitätspflicht dann
auch verletzt also diese neutralität war
immer auch politisch verstanden und
nicht wirklich also wirtschaftlich hat
man immer weiter
also es gibt ein neutralität recht und
es gibt eine neutralitätspolitik und ich
glaube man muss zwischen beiden
unterscheiden wie entstand das
eigentlich vielleicht können sie das
kurz sagen und dieser neutralität dieses
bild dessen erfindung war es eigentlich
ja da gibt es debatten darüber die hier
nicht alle reproduzieren wahrscheinlich
muss man sagen die neutralität hatte
viele viele viele väter und ist immer
wieder neu erfunden worden etwas
wichtiges war der wiener kongress 1815
wo sich dann wirklich auch die
europäischen großmächte dafür
interessiert haben dass da in der mitte
europas ein neutraler kleinstadt ist
über den man zum beispiel truppen
verschieben kann wenn es nötig ist oder
der der einfach still haltung mit dem
man noch geschäfte machen kann wenn
alles andere untergeht
also das war nicht nur etwas was die
schweiz sowie sich erfunden hat und
schönen darzustellen sondern da gibt es
das ist von anfang an eingebunden in
eine interessenpolitik jetzt sie haben
die kriegszeit schon erwähnt wir als
dieses gesprächs ist ja auch ein
schwerpunkt in srf derzeit macht 1945 zu
75 jahren kriegsende des zweiten
weltkriegs und da geht es um die rolle
der schweiz im zweiten weltkrieg aber
auch danach und da wir möchten jetzt mal
ein bisschen reden am am anfang
die schweiz war ja da auch offiziell
neutral aber sie haben kooperiert mit
der nazis wir haben kapital geliefert
rüstungsgüter geliefert
raub gold gekauft jüdische flüchtlinge
an der grenze abgewiesen und so weiter
wie groß war denn eigentlich der
handlungsspielraum
die wahl hatte die schweiz überhaupt
eine wahl auf dem überfall auf
frankreich 1940 war die schweiz
eingeschlossen von den achsenmächten und
das war klar dass sie kooperieren muss
oder wird auch um wirtschaftlich zu
überleben und es gab auf seiten der
alliierten da auch sehr viel verständnis
dafür
für diese kooperation es gibt dann aber
den moment gegen kriegsende in den
letzten kriegswochen kriegsmonaten
glaube also wo es auch wieder ein
korridor gab gegen westen wo kalla war
der nazi deutschland wird den krieg
verlieren
und da hat die schweiz immer noch
kooperiert und das ist eine frage danach
einfach auch nach dass eine kluge
politische entscheidung oder wird man da
irgendwann leichtsinnig also konkret zb
banken waren das spiel zu machen kaufte
die schweizerische nationalbank die hat
von nazi deutschland insgesamt etwa 1,2
milliarden im wert von 1,2 milliarden
franken gold übernommen
das war auch glaubt dass gold also gold
das nazi deutschland im zuge der
eroberungszüge die sie gemacht haben von
anderen nationalbanken einfach angesagt
und mitgenommen hat das gold war sehr
wichtig für deutschland mit gold konnte
man devisen kaufen und der fast der
ganze goldhandel der deutschen also der
goldexplorer lief über die schweiz
nun hat man noch nach dem krieg
behauptet es gab eigentlich einen
konsens dass die schweizerische
nationalbank gar nicht wissen konnte
dass das geld das gold ist also das ja
nicht davon in gutem glauben davon
ausgehen konnte dass die reichsbank
soviel goldbestände gehabt hat das ist
nachweislich nicht so man hat das
gewusst und die alliierten haben die
schweiz auch mehrfach am ende darüber
informiert dass man mit diesen
geschäften aufhören soll es gab ein
abkommen auch und da hat man sich dann
nicht daran gehalten und eben noch im
april 19.45 nochmal gold aufgekauft also
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe die
schweiz
ist viel zu spät ausgestiegen in
kooperation das ist ein hand frisst
keinen druck mehr gab es gab eine zeit
wo es einen druck gab auch viel
verständnis und dann hat das gekippt und
da ja da hätte man da hätte man absteigt
genau und ich habe gesagt nicht nur die
die hauptsache sondern auch über 20.000
jüdische flüchtlinge wurden an der
grenze abgewiesen die meisten davon
wurden dann getötet in kzs die schweiz
hat vor allem gegen ende eine sehr
restriktive flüchtlingspolitik vertreten
und schweizer diplomaten sollen ja auch
eine beteiligt gewesen sein an der
erfindung des juden stempels und wir
hören dazu mal ganz kurz zwei experten
stimmen an
[Musik]
ab 1933 bestand die politik des
bundesrats darin zu bestätigen die
schweiz habe nicht die mittel
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
1935 fand die konferenzführung statt
eine initiative des amerikanischen die
konferenz versuchte eine internationale
hilfsaktion für flüchtlinge zu
organisieren
doch praktisch alle demokratischen
starken erklärten es ist bedauerlich
aber wir haben keinen platz für all
diese flüchtlinge die schweiz
praktizierte eine extrem restriktive
asylpolitik speziell gegenüber juden im
jahr einen sehr anschaulichen aspekte
und das ist der berühmte stempel mit dem
buchstaben j in den pässen der deutschen
juden man weiß dass dieser stempel j in
einem protokoll akzeptiert wurde
und dieses wurde im oktober 1938
einstimmig durch den bundesrat
angenommen das ist deshalb bedeutend
weil ab diesem datum das schweizer recht
eine rassistische konzeption dieser
restriktive asylpolitik wurde in den
folgejahren angewendet insbesondere im
jahr 1942 als klar wurde dass die juden
von einer systematischen mit leider
modernsten industriellen mitteln
ausgeführten vernichtungspolitik bedroht
waren
ja das war ein kurzer ausschnitt aus dem
dock fielen die buchenwald kinder von
hansjürg zumstein den ganzen film können
sich morgen montagabend um 22 uhr 35 1
51 sehen wieviel antisemitismus war denn
da im spiel bei dieser
flüchtlingspolitik
die forschung hat gezeigt dass man das
was sie ohne antisemitische
vorstellungen das eigentlich auch nicht
erklären kann also da kommt
antisemitismus im spiel und es ist
wichtig auch im blick zu haben dass es
dann nicht einfach in den 30er jahren
auf kommt das thema antisemitismus
sondern antisemitismus
hinblick auf die zulassungspolitik und
migration in der schweiz schon nach dem
ersten weltkrieg eine rolle gespielt hat
in der legitimation etwa im kontext der
fremdenpolizei genau zu entscheiden wer
darf eigentlich ins land kommt und wer
nicht und wenn man sich da die quellen
anschaut
er ist das explizit dass vor allen
dingen ein damals im damaligen
sprachgebrauch sogenannte ostjuden nicht
ins land kommen sollten also dagegen
waren die gesetze schon gerichtet vor
dieser zeit in dem sinne gibt es eine
längere geschichte von
einwanderungsgeschichte und
antisemitismus in der schweiz und es
fällt nicht vom himmel da 1938 und in
dem sinne ist das eine geschichte mit
der mit der sich die schweiz auch
auseinandersetzen muss wobei ich und da
würde ich vielleicht doch noch gerne
reagieren wollen auf die aufgebote neben
haben doch noch mal die frage stellen
würde wäre eigentlich die schweiz ist
weil wir eben jetzt vom von der rolle
die die schweiz ist damit der quasi werk
des staates
gemeint ist damit die regierung gemeint
sind alle menschen gemeint und gerade in
diesem fall des umgangs mit flucht im
zweiten weltkrieg ist es ja wichtig auch
zuschauen wenn wir über
handlungsspielräume reden wer hat denn
eigentlich genau wie agiert es gab ja
auch in der zivilgesellschaft leute die
die auch entgegen staatlicher
entscheidung gehandelt haben unter
schweizer schweizer wir kennen wir
kennen die gründe ssten figuren ob das
grüninger ist oder schoko oder alt auch
konsul an der botschaft in budapest
karl lutz und das sind figuren die
natürlich auch für etwas stehen dass wir
aufpassen müssen nicht einfach von der
schweiz zu bringen sondern sehr genau
hinzuschauen wer hatte in welchem moment
welche handlungsspielräume
das ist nicht immer einfach
festzustellen aber ich glaube und das
zeigt ja auch und das ist eben
interessant die konstante
auseinandersetzung mit diesem thema
flucht schweiz zweiter weltkrieg seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg dass das
längst teil einer lebendigen
geschichtskultur ist das fängt an mit
dem ludwig bericht in den 50er jahren
das geht weiter über branchenbericht das
geht weiter über debatten in den 80er
jahren mit dem film das boot ist voll
mit der unabhängigen expertenkommission
also die außen nicht ja dann gehen auch
in den neunziger jahren dann eingesetzt
wird das heißt wir sehen dass diese
frage was für handlungsspielräume gab es
was für an verantwortung gab es die ist
seit jahrzehnten teil der
geschichtskultur der schweiz und die
kamen erst ziemlich spät dass in den
90er jahren muss man sagen oder diese
detailliert die erarbeitung einer
scheffczyk vielleicht die frage an sie
aus philosophischer sicht es gibt ja
diesen begriff der kollektivschuld jetzt
hat er erstmal diese gesagt so dass man
es gibt nicht die schweiz man muss immer
die einzelnen akteure anschauen welche
handlungsspielräume die haben können sie
mit diesem begriff dann etwas anfangen
kollektiv schon ja also ich stimme
natürlich völlig zu dass das man das
differenziert betrachten muss aber ich
dachte eigentlich schon dass die schweiz
gibt in vielen hinsichten ist die
schweiz natürlich eine realität und ich
glaube die welt wäre überrascht wenn das
ist die schweiz nicht gibt aber
natürlich haben sie völlig recht man man
muss sehr differenziert sich die
unterschiedlichen gruppen von
akteurinnen und akteuren anschauen und
schauen in welche rolle sie agiert haben
und vor welchem jahr wissens hintergrund
auch und erst dann kann man eigentlich
zu urteilen kommen und dann zeigt sich
die sachen sind häufig auch sehr sehr
schwierig aber wir müssen eben auch
sehen und jetzt komme ich ein bisschen
zur kollektivschuld das wird diesen ja
sehr vergifteten schwierigen begriff der
kollektivschuld haben ich glaube der so
emotionalisiert dass man den am besten
aus dem verkehr zieht weil er uns nicht
besonders weiterhilft aber es gibt eben
auch die neigung von menschen sich
spontan zu identifizieren
wenn irgendwo der schweizer name
dransteht also oder der oder dransteht
deutsch heute neigen dazu
wenn wenn irgendwo ein 1 1 bürger des
eigenen landes ein unheil anrichtet sich
schlecht dafür zu führen und erst im
nachgang sagen sie sich ich habe
eigentlich gar keinen grund dazu also es
gibt diese beiden beiden ein okay zur
kollektivschuld es ist ein bisschen
toxischer begriff im deutschen kontext
ich kann es jetzt für die schwarz nicht
so gut beurteilen weil die weil die
deutschen nachdem nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg sehr damit beschäftigt waren
ob die alliierten das deutsche volk als
ganzes zur verantwortung ziehen würden
für ihre verbrechen und die schrift die
schuldfrage von von karl jaspers nimmt
zum aufhänger plakate die es tatsächlich
gegeben hat das bestritten worden von
sehr guten historikern dass es die
gegeben hat aber mittlerweile ist
eindeutig gesichert plakate auf denen
man bilder aus den vernichtungslagern
gesehen hat und die wir an beschriftet
mit das ist eure schuld und das hat
natürlich historische rasiere ich euch
also es ist zumindest unbestimmt gewesen
was der aussagegehalt jeher ein sollte
und und karl jaspers hat dann sehr früh
angefangen sich genauer anzugucken was
damit eigentlich gemeint sein kann und
befürwortet da auch unter anderem den
kollektivschuld begriff in einem ganz
spezifischen sind nämlich in dem sinne
der politischen haftung der deutschen
also die idee ist dass die bevölkerung
17 dass die politische gemeinschaft die
bevölkerung eines landes die politische
rechte verfügt verantwortlich ist für
die regierung die sie hat und insofern
für die konsequenzen dieses handelns
einzustehen hat und karl jaspers war der
meinung in anbetracht der der verbrechen
die die deutschen begangen haben wäre
die sozusagen die auflösung dieses
politischen kollektivs eine ernst zu
nehmende option
die deutschen hätten keinen grund sich
darüber zu beklagen
das wäre also kollektivschuld in diesem
sinne der politischen haftung wie war
das in der schweiz für holler mit mit
dieser haftung also gab es irgendwie die
aufarbeitung hsb sie hat das etwas
angesprochen aber dann konkret
entschädigung neue versuche der
wiedergutmachungszahlungen aber so was
also für diese nachrichtenlosen vermögen
zum beispiel ja es ist eine sehr
schwierige frage oder ist eigentlich
auch keine historische frage oder keine
frage die historiker beantworten können
sondern eine politische frage
das heißt die historiker und
historikerinnen die versuchen zu
recherchieren was stattgefunden hat wer
welchen handlungsspielraum hat wer wann
welche entscheidungen getroffen hat
alles was danach kommt ist eine
politische entscheidung und das wiki an
ex profi gesagt hat dass begann sehr
sehr früh das ist nicht so dass einfach
heute die nachgeborenen über ein halbes
jahrhundert später jetzt mit bösem blick
auf die vergangenheit schauen und sagen
was sie alles falsch gemacht haben
sondern das begann direkt nach dem krieg
das begann unmittelbar vor 1945 begann
quasi dieser aufarbeitungsprozess wenn
man so sagen will was historiker machen
ist sie liefen eigentlich grundlagen
ausgangslagen dafür für diesen für diese
politische auseinandersetzung und auch
für die erinnerungskultur wir wissen ja
aus der sozialpsychologie als das sich
nicht nur individuen erinnern sondern
eben auch gesellschaften kollektive
maurice halbwachs ab 1939 ein sehr
schönes bücher in der liebe geschrieben
über dieses kollektiv über dieses
gemeinschaftliche soziale erinnern
historiker leisten dafür einen einen
beitrag für diese erinnerungskultur sie
können sie aber nicht steuern oder sie
können
recherchen zur verfügung stellen damit
sich gesellschaften in so einem prozess
überhaupt begeben können und
demokratische gesellschaften sollten
sich das leisten oder dumm haben sowie
teile herrscher haben historiker tom
nicht gern oder jeweiligen online
schreibt ja die haben diese ambivalenzen
auch nicht aus und die wollen immer eine
die sie eine schöne geschichte diese
heldengeschichte jetzt erleben wir aber
in einer demokratischen gesellschaft die
das aushält
sollte und man kann diesen prozess auch
nachvollziehen und es gab tatsächlich
dann so etwas
es gab kleine gesten oder die schweiz
hat im washingtoner abkommen noch 19 45
eingewilligt 250 millionen zu bezahlen
aber man hat man hat es gut gemacht oder
walter stucki der die verhandlungen
geführt hat der hat einen gut gelandet
man hat keine schuld an erkannt man hat
nicht gesagt dass ist eine
wiedergutmachung für begangenes unrecht
sondern man hat so drehen können das ist
ein freiwilliger beitrag an den
wiederaufbau europas auch nicht günstig
davon gekommen und dann später kam sogar
1,25 milliarden 1998 dann von den
schweizer banken vor allem auch für
diese nachrichtenlosen vermögen
das sieht man einfach so konkret die
zahlen ich finde das irgendwie noch
erstaunlich herr scheffczyk also kann
man irgendwie schuld mit geld begleichen
oder ist das eher ein symbolischer
betrag der da gesprochen werden darf ich
noch einen punkt nach tragen zudem zudem
zudem kollektivschuld begriffen dann
können wir ja gerne vielleicht auf die
auf diese frage noch kommen weil ich
weil ich eben gesagt hatte dass das dass
das ein toxischer begriff ist also in
der in der deutschen diskussion ist es
so gewesen dass und da glaube ich
unterscheidet sich der deutsche fall
wirklich grundsätzlich von von dem
schweizer fall dass die deutsche
bevölkerung ihre massenhafte beteiligung
an dem nationalsozialistischen unrechts
eigentlich verleugnet hat bis in die
90er jahren verleugnet hat und der
kollektivschuld begriff eigentlich ein
begriff den man eingesetzt hat um um
genau diesen befunden zu verdrängen das
sei als 1995 der goltz hitlers willige
helfer erschienen ist hat der spiegel
getitelt
hier haben wir doch nazi mäßiges denken
den deutschen wird kollektiv collect
kollektivschuld vorgeworfen dabei haben
doch viele leute gar nichts gemacht das
war aber nicht der punkt sondern der
punkt war
das millionen von deutschen sehr
bereitwillig kooperiert haben
beim nazi unrecht und insofern und das
ist sozusagen diese diese toxische seite
dieses begriffes das natürlich ist es
richtig dass man die zugehörigkeit zu
einem kollektiv wir jetzt keine schuld
zusammenhang allein begründet es sind
die individuellen beiträge
aber in manchen fällen geschieht dies
eben millionenfach und dafür die schweiz
könnte man vielleicht die frage stellen
ja selbst wenn es so wäre dass das viele
entscheidungen durch mitglieder von
politischen wirtschaftlichen eliten
geführt worden seien getroffen worden
sind ohne dass die breite bevölkerung
das mitbekommen hat ist die frage zu
stellen
naja was muss eigentlich die bevölkerung
welche fragen muss die bevölkerung eines
demokratischen staates eigentlich
stellen an ihre eliten und da waren die
bedingungen in der schweiz natürlich
etwas günstiger als in anderen staaten
vielleicht gehen wir noch einen schritt
weiter sie haben dann ein buch
geschrieben das trägt den titel
verantwortung für historisches unrecht
und es eine seltsame sache dass es das
gibt das wir heute irgendwie auch
verantwortlich sind für das was
generationen vor uns gemacht haben wir
waren ja kausal gar nicht daran
beteiligt
und trotzdem sagen sie haben wir
bestimmte pflichten
warum ist das eigentlich so ja also
erstens weil in einem bestimmten sinne
historisches unrecht ja noch nicht viele
generationen zurückliegen soll also das
oder muss dass das historische unrecht
von dem wir jetzt viel geredet haben
dass das ist ja eins wo die opfer und
täter bis vor kurzem auf jeden fall noch
unter uns waren jetzt zunehmend weniger
deshalb kann man kann man das gar nicht
so sagen dass das wir hier ein problem
der historischen distanz aber ich selbst
bin 1983 geboren
ja richtig sehen was ich welche
irgendwelche verantwortung habe ich
obwohl ich nicht teil war damals ja sie
haben keine verantwortung
als jemand der der daran beteiligt
gewesen ist
diesem dieses unrecht zu begehen aber
werden dieses unrecht im namen von
begangen wurde also durch eine
politische körperschaft der mitglied sie
sind die schweiz die schweiz
beispielsweise dann wenn dann sind sie
dann tragen sie mit verantwortung für
die für die erfüllung von pflichten ja
aus diesem unrecht resultieren warum das
ist erstmal intuitive nicht blau silber
finde ich aber würden sie nicht mal
eigentlich auch mal spiele würden sie ja
aber würden sie nicht meinen dass wenn
ich ihnen jetzt ihre bücher da wegnehme
und kaputt mache dass ich ihnen etwas
schulden nämlich die diese beiden bücher
und ich soll den schaden wieder gut
machen und glaube dass das ist ein
relativ starren sie ja der akteure sie
haben das verursacht kann ich sie zur
verantwortung sie ja richtig aber wir
also die die grundidee ist doch dass sie
in ihren rechten verletzt sind und dass
die dass die moralische gemeinschaft sie
in ihren rechten als opfer von unrecht
wieder herstellen sollte diese pflicht
trifft primär da haben sie völlig recht
diese pflicht trifft primär die personen
die das unrecht angerichtet hat und dann
schuldig ihnen etwas nämlich erstens die
anerkenntnis des moralischen fehler ja
sie sie können von mir erwarten dass ich
mich entschuldige aber auch die
wiedergutmachung des materiellen
schadens
das ist die frage die sie eben hatten
also und diese pflicht haben nicht nur
sie die der mir die bücher weggenommen
hat sondern weil der alltag ihre kinder
oder ihre eltern unter umständen
personen also und da muss man dann
genauer gucken aber die einfach zu sagen
na ja wenn der halten wenn der täter
oder die täterin weg ist dann bleiben
die opfer von unrecht mit mit den folgen
des unrechts
allein die scheint mir nun gar nicht
plausibel zu sein
[Musik]
wenn ich da kurz noch mal wieder andere
vielleicht ein blick vom historiker
darauf richten können weil ich meine
schuld ist ja erstmal noch keine
historischer begriff indem sie das ist
quasi ein 1 1 1 1 richten vor dem
hintergrund von bestimmten moralischen
oder rechtlichen ordnung
ich habe den eindruck dass die frage des
der historischen schuld die debatte
einengt also wenn man wirklich
verantwortung und nochmal auf diese
dieser diesem zusammenhang von von
vergangenheit gegenwart und zukunft
angeht glaube ich dass das eigene
argumentation es gibt gewissermaßen eine
verpflichtung als mitglied einer
gesellschaft aber die andere wäre doch
umgekehrt zu sagen gehen wir von der
gegenwart aus die gegen gegenwart ist
geworden aus einer geschichte die wir
miteinander reden wie die gesellschaft
aussieht
all diese dinge sind durch eine
historische entwicklung so geworden wir
stehen gewissermaßen wir leben in in
diesem in diesem prozess der da noch
weitergeht und die gegenwart trägt die
spuren der vergangenheit die situation
genau und war sie in dem sinne ist es
notwendig sich über die die
vergangenheit zu unterhalten um diesen
diesen bedeutungs zusammenhang
herzustellen indem wir überhaupt unser
erleben und handeln irgendwie einbetten
können indem das was wir tun und denken
sinn erhält in dem sinne geht es ja
nicht nur um quasi wer muss
verantwortung übernehmen sondern welche
verantwortung wollen wir als
gesellschaft übernehmen weil wir denken
es ist notwendig um die zukunft anders
gestalten zu können ein beispiel wenn
ich nun auf diesen antisemitismus zurück
gehen darf der ist ja heute nicht weg
und wenn wir den befund sagen dass es
gibt weiterhin antisemitismus dann hilft
es uns in die vergangenheit zu schauen
ja warum ist er denn heute überhaupt da
und zwar nicht nur in unseren köpfen
sondern in welchen strukturen hatte sich
angela und das trifft ja auch auf
koloniale denkmuster zu ralf latenten
rassismus oder expliziten rassismus und
die schweiz ich habe es gesagt hatte
selbst keine kolonien aber war irgendwie
auch verstrickt damals in dieses ganze
system
inwiefern denn vielleicht können sie das
kurz erläutern
ja also in der forschung hat man da
schöne begriffe wie sekundär
imperialismus und kolonialismus ohne
kolonien großen und ganzen kann man
sagen dass die schweiz in sehr
unterschiedlicher form und das muss man
jetzt wieder sehr genau sagen weil es in
dem fall in der tat nicht um den start
geht sondern um einzelne akteure wie
unternehmen wie missionen und
missionarinnen einzelpersonen aus
wanderinnen sollte also einzelne figuren
die eben innerhalb dieser dieser neuen
weltordnung des europäischen
kolonialismus und imperialismus daran
bestimmte leistungen erbringen oder an
bestimmten stellen auch davon
profitieren so kann man es auch sagen ob
das jetzt nur großen weltweiten
geschlechtes baum wurde handelns ist und
der produktion von von baumwoll waren
das ist alles sehr gut aufgearbeitet von
kolleginnen und kollegen und ich glaube
der punkt ist einfach nicht klar zu
machen
reden wir jetzt über die zeit über
schuld und ich würde wirklich sagen das
ist viel wichtiger sich klar zu machen
die debatte nicht mit der schuld
anzufangen sondern zu sagen und das gibt
es natürlich in der schweiz genauso in
deutschland es gibt eine verdrängung
leistung quasi anzuerkennen dass die
schweiz die sich so daran gewöhnt als
kleinstaat eingehegt in der mitte von
europa zu sehen haben die teil von
globalen verflechtungen ist und das
nicht seit gestern seit der frühen
neuzeit im sklavenhandel und so weiter
und so fort
und wenn wir die schweiz von heute
verstehen wollen müssen wir diese
geschichte verstehen sonst haben wir ein
komplett falsches bild davon in was für
einer gesellschaft und gemeinschaft wir
überhaupt leben und vielleicht noch ein
einwand auf diese idee von mitglieder
einer einer politischen gemeinschaft in
dem fall
wir haben wir jetzt noch die
herausforderung das gilt im übrigen auch
für deutschland die holocaust debatte
wir leben in migrations gesellschaften
das heißt ein großteil der bevölkerung
ist nicht nur damals auch nicht an das
nicht mal die familien waren damals
anwesend und ich glaube es ist enorm
wichtig sehr gut darüber zu sprechen wie
man eigentlich die auseinandersetzung
mit kolonialismus oder in deutschland
mit holocaust so aufstellt dass man auch
keine falschen illusionen hegt
wer da eigentlich welche verantwortung
trägt und dann vielleicht zu dem punkt
zu kommen denn das ist unser aller
geschichte auch der kolonialismus ist
geschichte allergie da sind sowohl
diejenigen die in der nächsten
generation in der schweiz leben als auch
die vielleicht aus ländern mit
kolonialvergangenheit eingewandert sind
und dass ich auch eine chance wenn wir
heute schuldlos liegen schreibt mir die
debatte schon zuzusagen bevor sie
losgegangen wird
ich möchte jetzt das buch von ihnen
vorstellen frau aller transit handelt
geld und warenströme im globalen
kapitalismus sie aber nämlich genau
diese historische arbeit auch mit
geleistet und ein wichtiges stück dazu
beigetragen dass wir verstehen wie die
verflechtungen die zusammenhänge war
dass die schweiz eine ganz entscheidende
rolle gespielt hat auch die
globalisierung das was wir so nennen
voranzutreiben und nicht nur mit import
und export sondern vor allem mit dem was
ihren zwischenhandel oder transit tanzen
nennen möchten sie kurz erläutern was
das ist ja transit handel ist ein
bisschen ein schwieriger begriff weil er
etwas falsches serviert er suggeriert
einen transit durch ein land und beide
waren transit handel ist es eben so dass
ist zwischenhandel wo die waren gar
nicht hierher kommen also in die schweiz
nur die kapitalströme kommen in die
schweiz also das ist handel von firmen
die hier ansässig sind die affen
baumwolle in indien verkaufen sie direkt
in den usa und der gewinn fließt in die
schweiz
und mich hat einfach interessiert das
ist heute weiß man die schweiz ist eine
sehr große rohstoffhandels nation also
etwa rund ein fünftel des gesamten
global gehandelten der gesamten global
gehandelten rohstoffe werden über die
schweiz gehandelt
und ich wollte einfach wissen weit war
nicht auch so und hat herausgefunden
dass ist nicht erst seit vergessen
sodass ist seit eigentlich beginnen dann
fordern seit mitte des 19 jahrhunderts
so dass hier sehr viele firmen ansässig
sind eben ein sehr sehr globales
geschäft betreiben und da kann man jetzt
noch einmal zurückkommen vielleicht auch
diesen auf diese vorstellung von die sie
an wissen suggeriert haben am anfang
oder es gibt die schweiz hat immer auch
so konkret sind sie hat teilgenommen an
den bösen sachen und geschäften die da
irgendwo liefen
und wenn man mit einem
ein blick auf die geschichte der schweiz
und akteuren die hier einfach ihren
firmensitz hatten schaut dann sieht man
die schweiz jahr war wirklich eine zeit
treiber lädt oder diese firmen das waren
globalisierungs akteure die haben etwas
vorangetrieben und die waren
selbstverständlich das ist ja auch
logisch also die schweiz ist ja nicht
eine eine abgeschlossene insel in der
welt das war ein land das sehr sehr früh
sehr global vernetzt war es
wahrscheinlich das einzige land der welt
das eine industrielle revolution auf
entfernten exportmärkten abgestützt hat
weil die die märkte in europa in frühen
neunzehnten jahrhundert die waren so die
hat da gab es hohe zölle also hat man in
die ferne exportiert und man hat eben
nicht nur exportiert man hat handel
getrieben mit allen möglichen aber nicht
da gab es ja damals gar nicht vor 18
achten wird sich sondern firmen und
einzelhändler die das gemacht einzelne
händler man kann auch sagen man kann
schon sehen wo die etwa lokalisiert
waren
das waren vor allem junge männer aus
begüterten familien vom land in der nähe
von winterthur zum beispiel oder basel
protestantische familien denen die
zugänge verwehrt waren zu den
klassischen karrieren arzt anwalt und zu
in den städten die waren nicht auf
städtische gymnasium zugelassen und für
die war der globale handel für die war
das abenteuer oder da konnte man mal
eben wohin fahren und da was aufbauen
man braucht er natürlich kapital das ist
ein sehr kapitalintensives geschäft und
viele haben einfach es gibt verschiedene
gründe die ändern sich auch im lauf der
zeit haben das sehr erfolgreich
mitgemischt und die waren
selbstverständlich eingebunden und auch
zur zeit des imperialismus des
kolonialismus in diese kolonialen
struktur die haben sehr profitiert von
diesen colin jahren strukturen das war
natürlich toll hat ihm haben die briten
schon mal die eisenbahn gebaut und eine
bank organisiert in indien
sie haben den kolonialmächten auch
dienstleistungen erbracht die basler
handelsgesellschaft hat
selbstverständlich in afrika ihre
warenlager auch auktions depot zur
verfügung gestellt wenn es einmal nötig
war
das war das war eine sehr sehr
beschränkt jetzt haben sie gesagt die
schweiz weltweit wichtigste drehscheibe
für rohstoffe und das hat sich ja noch
mal beschleunigt ab den nullerjahren
also muss ich schnell die zahlen schauen
finde ich jetzt gehört nicht nein genau
da 2 milliarden im jahr 2002 auf rund 25
milliarden franken im jahr 2017 und
viele von diesen alten transit als wir
haben sie danach konkurs gegangen viele
ausländische firmen wie glencore und so
weiter sitzen jetzt hier
warum gab es an diesem wandel darum die
nullerjahre ja getan ist eine sehr
wichtige beobachtung oder wenn wir
kontinuität in der geschichte ist
eigentlich sehr schwierige kategorie man
hat man kontinuität an aber eigentlich
ändern sich alle parameter hier einen
sehr speziellen fall eine kontinuität
sehr lange kontinuität eines geschäfts
das ist dienstleistungssektor dass die
einnahmen die diese filme machen die
zahlen auf die zahlungsbilanz sein und
man kann das aber fast nicht messen es
ist schwer zu messen auch man hat für
frühere jahre
heute geht es besser aber man hat nicht
so gute daten weil weil die ware nicht
hierher kam weil man keine zoll
dekorationen hatte weil er es fehlen
zahlen also immer nur noch intransparent
gehört es war es war intransparent das
ist immer noch ein intransparentes
geschäft heute und man sieht dann es
ändern sich laufend verschiedenste
parameter und dann gegen die
jahrhundertwende sind tatsächlich viele
alte schweizer filmen firmen nicht alle
nicht es geht noch weiter die alt sind
aber sind konkurs gegangen
die einen haben sich verspekuliert man
hat diversifiziert mann hat in sachen
investiert man nicht so viel ahnung
hatte davon zum beispiel in
immobilienmärkte
ein anderer grund ist dass die volumen
sehr sehr gestiegen sind es gab eine
integration im sektor also
firmen sind zusammengeschmolzen zu groß
groß imperien quasi es gab auch eine
integration der seine eine vertikale
integration dass firmen auch im bergbau
auf einer tätig waren und nicht mehr nur
im handel und lust nachher auch im
verkauf also dass sie auf einmal
begonnen die ganze lieferkette
abzudecken und es gab so eine zeit ja
den 70er 80er jahren also eine jüngere
generation da an die an die leitung
dieser firmen kam die wirklich derzeit
alles wurde oder selbst ruhig mal konnte
ich sehr viel geld machen zum beispiel
auch den sekundärmärkten mit
spekulationen oder an der börse
und die ja das war einfach das geschäft
ist risikoreicher geworden
und wenn einem dann die bank eben man
das vertrauen entzieht und sagt wir
glauben nicht mehr dass eure erste
geschäfte decken dann gibt es ein
problem ja und die großen firmen die
heute hier sind das sind eigentlich das
allermeiste diesen zugewandert die haben
hier einfach einen firmensitz es gab
hier schon eine infrastruktur für dieses
geschäft wunderbar totales staat und die
ganze die sind in der genferseeregion in
der innerschweiz und steuergünstigen
orten steuerprivilegien geschäftig sie
sind ja auch promovierter ökonom
philosoph mit wem darf man dann
eigentlich geschäfte machen wo muss man
die grenze ziehen die grenzen der
neutralität vielleicht also man man
sollte mit mit leuten keine geschäfte
machen von denen man weiß dass sie
verbrecherisch arbeiten und
verbrecherische ziele verfolgen würde
ich mal auf einer ganz allgemein ebene
dazu sagen und
ich frage mich ob die die rohstoff
importierenden nationen und die nationen
die mit rohstoffhandel zu tun haben
dieser verantwortung immer in
ausreichendem maße gerecht werden und da
bin ich wenn ich sie da richtig
verstanden habe ganz auf der seite von
frau halle und s-bahn gysi unser
verständnis für historische
entwicklungen und kontinuitäten kann uns
helfen uns zu sensibilisieren für die
problematik zeitgenössische des
zeitgenössischen welt rohstoffmarktes da
stellt sich sehr wohl die frage und ich
glaube nicht nur für die schweiz aber
vielleicht für die schweiz besonders
weil sie mächtige akteure hier ist was
wir eigentlich tun können um die um die
welt rohstoffmärkte in einer moralisch
akzeptablen weise zu organisieren und
das sind sie nicht und ich glaube dass
das auch bekannt ist
wir kaufen und importieren rohstoffe bei
häufig sehr problematischen regimen die
mit den einkünften aus dem
rohstoffhandel alles mögliche machen
aber nicht die mittel einsetzen um zum
wohle der politischen gemeinwesen zu
werden
und da gibt sehr wohl vorschläge auf was
man da tun könnte auch auf
internationaler ebene und die schweiz
gewöhnt sich ja jetzt auch wie ich
verstehe auch daran auch ihre eigene
größe etwas mehr zu akzeptieren und auch
der welt zu verraten dass sie das selber
jetzt auch bereit ist zu geben die
schweiz ist keine kleine nation in
vielen hinsichten und mit größe kommt
größere verantwortung und die sollte die
schweiz nutzen
[Musik]
vielleicht müssen wir noch über ein
anderes kapitel reden wir haben jetzt
die schweiz als komplizin aber oft ist
es ja auch so dass die politik dann zur
komplizin der wirtschaft wird ein
konkretes beispiel wäre
der umgang mit italienischen
gastarbeitern über den sich auch viel
geforscht haben die migrationsgeschichte
diese gastarbeiter wurden diskriminiert
und ausgebeutet und die wirtschaft hat
profitiert und die politik hat sozusagen
die regeln bereitgestellt warum passiert
so was wie gehen wir damit um heute naja
also man muss ich erst mal vor augen
halten dass in der zeit des
wirtschaftsbooms also drei so 30 jahre
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg in der
schweiz das wirtschaftswachstum auch nur
deswegen so stattfinden und die stadt
gewundert weil man auf millionen muss
man sagen millionen von ausländischen
arbeitskräften gesetzt hat die zu viel
günstigeren löhnen und sage ich mal viel
schlechteren bedingungen der arbeit
geleistet haben die viele schweizerin
schweizer nicht mehr machen wollten
auf feldern in fabriken und so weiter
also zwischen 9 45 und 75 gab es rund 85
millionen erstzulassungen für leute die
ins land kommen und einfach um die
größenordnung hast so 65 mio ja genau
also leute die quasi die zulassung
jemand mit arbeit ins land kommt das ist
die grundlage auf der auch der wohlstand
generiert wurde in der sich die schweiz
zu einer mittelschicht gesellschaft
gewandelt hat in dem quasi aus
schweizerischer arbeiten zu
facharbeitern aufsteigen konnten durch
diese sogenannte unterschicht um diese
unterrichtung hat deswegen funktionieren
können weil leute aus sehr armen
regionen aus europa in vor allem halt
doch sie total sid sid italien kam und
unter bedingungen gearbeitet haben die
sonst für schweizer uhren schweizer
schlecht vorstellbar gewesen werden in
dieser zeit und das ist die grundlage
dass der gesellschaftliche wohlstand in
der wir auch im ein pfeiler in der wir
heute leben mit noch den punkt dass
viele dieser menschen und das war die
idee damals ja deswegen hat man quasi
mit dem saisonstart so heißt das
eigentlich das produkt so zu regeln dass
die leute wieder gehen sie kommen
arbeiten und gehen das war quasi das
modell und dieses modell waren sie am
letztlich planwirtschaftliches modell
nur das leben ist keine planwirtschaft
in dem sinne weder
die leute noch die firmen noch viele
andere argumente sprachen dafür dass
wirklich da dieser dieser rotation die
ganze zeit stattfindet letztendlich sind
viele geblieben
viele menschen sind geblieben sind teil
der schweiz geworden
von allen seiten wie gesagt eher
ungeplant und damit hat sich auch die
sichtweise verändert menschen die vorher
vielleicht gesagt hätte na ja gut ich
bin bereit unter den bedingungen hier zu
arbeiten weil da wo ich herkomme sieht
es noch viel schlechter aus übernehmen
auch die vorstellung und wertigkeiten
diese gesellschaft stellen fest moment
mal was uns da passiert ist
wir sind schlechter bezahlt wurden wir
durften uns auch familie nicht holen
viele kinder lebten ja auch im
verborgenen hier also man spricht von 15
bis 20 tausend kindern in den 70er
jahren die aufgrund der des des statuts
eigentlich nicht hätten da sein dürfen
hat familien auseinander gerissen und
auf einmal ist das nicht einfach eine
episode von ausländern die kommen und
gehen sondern es wird teil der schweizer
geschichte das werden das sind heute
schweizerinnen und schweizer in der
dritten generation
die politik hat mit gesetzen das
ermöglicht dass diese für
wirtschaftswachstum in der form
stattfinden konnte und das wurde auch
kritisiert wenn wir von
handlungsspielraum das wurde damals
kritisiert die lebensumstände dieser
dieser menschen in vielerlei hinsicht
und wenn wir heute also von heute auf
dieser zeit schauen stellt sich wieder
die verantwortung für wie gehen wir
damit um und auch hier würde ich
eigentlich trotzdem sagen fangen wenn
ich bei der schuld an sondern gehen wir
erst mal davon aus zuschauen was ist da
genau passiert in dem ersten schritt und
in einem zweiten schritt das finde ich
noch wichtiger sie gucken wer ist
eigentlich dass wir das hier
verantwortung übernehmen muss und der
fehler der jetzt passieren könnte wäre
zu sagen wir schweizer müssen diese
schuld irgendwo übernimmt dabei ist wir
schweizerinnen schweiz hat sich dadurch
komplett geändert das heißt wenn wir
heute verantwortung dafür übernehmen als
schweizerinnen und schweizer und das bin
ich jetzt seit 2009 10 auch dann heißt
das auch dass die kinder und
kindeskinder dieser menschen ja auch
dazu gehören und die frage der
verantwortung scheint mir da wichtig
aber wenn wir auf diese zeit schauen und
verantwortung übernehmen
danach gibt es eine chance auch eine
neue kollektivität zu entwickeln
am start jetzt einfach nur in der
schuldfrage zu sagen diese schuld und
wir sind die opfer und dann
polarisierung voranzutreiben die das was
aber nicht heißen soll dass es nicht
fälle gibt in denen strafbar dinge
passiert sind
das ist eine andere sache oder ob man
nicht auch sagt im fall dieser kinder
dass man das vielleicht auch ähnlich wie
im umgang mit den verdingkinder und da
hat mit stativen versorgung durchaus
auch über andere formen der
wiedergutmachung sprechen kann
aber das ist nicht die aufgabe von
historikern historiker das zu regeln
aber trotzdem sind sie ein historiker
der nicht nur zurückschauen sondern auch
nach vorne es ist ein dach mitglied des
instituts neue schweiz und diese schweiz
aus irgendwie aufs neue zu betonen
welche forderungen sind gehen damit
einher mit diesem mit diesem neuen und
was ist damit gemeint
naja also so ein bisschen mit
augenzwinkern warum wir diesen tag so
genannt haben neue schweiz weil so neu
ist das gar nicht mit dem neuen schweiz
das erste mal hat leonard ragaz nach dem
ersten welt gegen bestseller
veröffentlicht mit dem titel die neue
schweiz mit einem modell nach dieser
katastrophe des ersten weltkrieges ein
genossenschaftlich christlich
genossenschaftliches modell für die
schweiz
in den 30er jahren gab es eine front ist
ish also faschistische gruppe die von
der neuen schweiz sprachen und ende des
zweiten weltkriegs hat die
sozialdemokratie ein neues programm mit
dem namen neue schweiz veröffentlicht wo
es darum ging quasi die arbeiterschaft
stärker einzubinden in die gesellschaft
und für uns war interessant zu sagen
wenn wir von der neuen schweiz sprechen
heißt dass nicht die alte gibt es nicht
mehr es gibt einen pfad zur
vergangenheit das eben nicht sondern zu
sagen jede geschichtskultur die den
zusammenhang herstellt muss auch den
sinn dafür bewahren neu anfangen zu
können und da möchte ich noch mal das
fand ich noch wichtig nietzsche hat mal
wichtige arbeit geschrieben in den 18
70er jahren so auch den gefahren eines
zu viel sun geschichte also wir müssen
erinnern wir müssen auf arbeiten aber
wir müssen auch vergessen das kennen wir
alle auch individuell manchmal ist es
gut gewisse dinge im leben besser zu
vergessen dass familien segens willen
und in dem sinne ist dass auch die
bedingungen einem gewissen moment
dazu sagen okay das alles passiert aber
lasst uns jetzt gemeinsam neu anfangen
also dieses neu anfangen scheint mir ein
punkt zu sein den man auch wirklich im
blick haben muss wenn man über
änderungen redet erinnern vergessen den
großen bogen sehen aber auch den willen
zu haben
hinzuschauen und dann zu sagen und jetzt
fangen wir gemeinsam an machen was neues
aus der geschichte lernen wir sind fast
schon am ende dieser diskussion was
könnte das heißen aus der geschichte zu
lernen ganz konkret für die schweiz hier
und heute narrhalla
es gibt verschiedene aspekte also was
man nicht kann ist aus der geschichte
handlungsanleitungen werden nicht so
eins zu eins man kann ich dann aber dort
haben sich so gemacht jetzt kopieren mir
dass geschichte wiederholt sich in dem
sie nicht aber man kann sehr sehr viel
aus der geschichte lernen eben zum
beispiel informierte entscheidungen
treffen für die zukunft oder das fand
ich sehr wichtig was kann es bis jetzt
gesagt hat dieses gemeinsam
weiterzugehen das nicht noch mal die
frage auf die sie zu beginn ist zu
beginn gestellt haben für wen machen wir
das eigentlich für uns für den halter
für uns als gesellschaft für das wird
eine immer schwierigere frage
je weiter die dinge zurückliegen oder
also opfer sterben auch opfer sterben
irgendwann und ich glaube man macht es
eben für alle für alle
wir machen das auch für uns um
informiert gemeinsam die zukunft
gestalten zu können das ist
wahrscheinlich der größte lerneffekt aus
der geschichte dass geschichte kein
automatismus ist oder das ist nicht
etwas was einfach so abläuft
in eine richtung und dann immer besser
wäre dann hat man dann
wirtschaftsaufschwung nach der zweiten
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg oder die
trommel und daher und dann an
innovationen und dann kommt das internet
und es wird einfach immer besser so ist
geschichte läuft nicht so der geschichte
ist immer komplex und das ist die arbeit
von historiker und sie wird gemacht sie
bestimmen auch geschichte wird gemacht
geschichte es nicht ja es gibt dieses
schöne bild des französischen historiker
slowene hat mal gesagt die historische
tatsachen sie nicht wie sandkörner die
liga nicht einfach irgendwo am strand wo
man kann sie dann einsammeln und
nebeneinander stellen sind alle etwa
gleich groß und gleich viel wert
und dann hat man dann so quasi in der
chronologie noch drehen und dann ist das
geschichte das ist nicht geschichte
geschichte ist welches geschichte eine
und selbstverständlich und kunst oder
historiker strafe gut der
historikerinnen und historiker zeigen
uns dass die dinge nicht unbedingt so
sind wie wir schon immer geglaubt haben
dass ihr dass sie gewesen sind sondern
sondern anders opfer sind manchmal auch
hätte zum glück es gibt zuschauer es ist
es ist komplex oder man hat politik und
wirtschaft spielen ineinander um das
soziale spielt dann auch noch mit und da
hat man in der schweiz oft muss man
sagen ja auf der sozialen seite keine
sehr gute rolle gespielt
herr scheffczyk die schlussfrage haben
sie mit bitte um eine kurze antwort was
wäre eine wichtige lektion aus der
geschichte kann man in erster linie mal
lernen dass es sie gibt und viele neigen
dazu zu sagen die geschichte die
vergangenheit ist weniger wirklich als
die gegenwart und die zukunft deshalb
sagen wir uns darum kümmern
ich denke dass die vergangenheit einen
ebenbürtigen status als als etwas hat
was wir ernst nehmen müssen und aus der
vergangenheit kommen pflichten auf uns
zu wir müssen verstehen worin diese
pflichten bestehen
aber was glaube ich nicht geht ist zu
sagen eben weil wir jetzt verstanden
haben dass gegenwart und zukunft wichtig
sind und die ansprüche aus der
vergangenheit in konkurrenz stehen zu
dem was wir in gegenwart und zukunft
machen wollen verlangen wir jetzt von
den opfern und den betroffenen von von
vergangenem unrecht zu vergessen
ich glaube das ist keine position die
man einen also natürlich kann man die
position einnehmen kann aber keine die
man einnehmen sollte die geschichte ist
ambivalent komplexen darf auf keinen
fall vergessen werden und sie sollen sie
ihren heute wirken das nehme ich sehr
gerne mit herr scheffczyk frau aber
herzlichen dank für das gespräch
ja dann gar ihn fürs mitdenken
jetzt gleich geht es hier weiter mit
einem der die generation seiner eltern
als komplizen der nazis verabscheute
volker schlöndorff der deutsche
filmemacher verließ die brd und lernt in
frankreich wie man gute filme macht dazu
gehören etwa die blechtrommel nach
günter grass oder auch homo faber nach
max frisch und an dieser stelle nochmals
der hinweis auf unseren multimedialen
schwerpunkt 19 45 meter drama-serie
frieden mit zwei doppeln und
verschiedenen online produktion die
webseite srf punkt ch / 19 45 bündelt
dieses große angebot dass sie auf keinen
fall verpassen sollten um nächste woche
reden wir hier angesichts der
zunehmenden überlastung der spitäler in
der schweiz über die vielleicht
schwierigste frage der ethik überhaupt
nämlich die triage wem sorgen wir helfen
wenn wir nicht allen helfen können und
darf man menschenleben gegeneinander
abwägen
darüber rede ich nächste woche mit dem
schweizer philosophen adriano mannino
und nun wünsche ich ihnen erst mal einen
schönen sonntag und bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]